so but let me actually uh
drag us back down to something basic if
a person
wanted to buy bitcoin
store bitcoin how do they actually do it
yeah so there's a couple of different
ways to kind of uh
acquire bitcoin and in every way you've
got to exchange
some form of value for bitcoin right
which is part of why
it has values because you're giving up
value so um
in one way is to exchange uh
energy and computational power for
bitcoin so you can
mine it you can literally take uh
computer power that you have you can
rent it to the network and run that
software and then it will pay you
a portion of the kind of daily revenue
uh
off that system you can acquire bitcoin
in exchange for your power
uh and your computational um kind of
contribution and that's the fundamental
principle behind bitcoin is the proof of
work
so i got a hundred bucks uh like i use
cash app
uh the you know they uh there's coinbase
there's all these
exchanges like how do i convert my
hundred dollars
to uh to bitcoin is there something
disclaimer this is not financial advice
and this is just
us uh talking and just your opinions
just do not use this to invest
or take us financial expertise
that said uh like uh is there something
you recommend that's an easy entry point
for somebody
that's like hmm i wonder if i can
convert this hundred dollars into
whatever amount of bitcoin what do you
recommend what are the options
so there's a lot of options uh i'm
heavily biased i went out and i
scoured the market looked at all of them
i've invested a lot of money in a
company called block fi
that basically um basically has
financial products for crypto investors
so you can go you can take
dollars or other currency you have you
can convert it through an exchange
uh you can leave it on these interest
bearing accounts you can earn interest
just like you would earn in a
traditional account but
higher levels of interest because it's
this new thing or you can withdraw it
and you can put it into
cold storage on a hardware device you
can leave it in a software wall there's
kind of all these storage options
uh so block file is you know kind of the
one that i'm biased towards because
so block files or sorry to interrupt uh
so block fi
a is a bitcoin only or is it an exchange
with the
other crypto it's got a bunch of
different ones yeah they basically are
agnostic
to what it is um but they provide uh
kind of financial
you know products to crypto investors
okay so you mentioned a few
interesting ideas that'd be nice for
people who would not be familiar
with it uh cold storage hot storage uh
what does that mean so like
i go to a website and i convert dollars
to bitcoin
that's a kind of storage that's like
online banking
right what else is there
so there's a couple of different things
that you can do right and let's use the
legacy system as kind of an example so
if i want to um get currency
and i put in my bank account it sits
there i have to trust that the bank
doesn't go under nobody steals it all
this kind of stuff there's insurance for
it right
there's all these kind of benefits in
the legacy system to make sure that as
long as i don't have you know millions
and millions of dollars there i'm going
to be protected
pretty much if anything happens through
fdic insurance
if i want to do that i'm taking that
counterparty risk though
so it's mitigated but there's still
counterparty risk i'm counting on that
bank
but it is easier to move it around right
if all of a sudden you call me up and
say hey send me some money i can
press a couple buttons on my computer
and it'll send it to you
if i want deeper level of security i can
go and i can get the physical dollars
and i can go and i can you know put
under my mattress right
and i can say you know what it's not
gonna be as easy to send it to you
immediately
but if i really want to i can go
underneath my mattress pretty quickly i
can grab it
i can get it back to the bank and then i
can send you the money
the third thing i could do is i could
basically take those physical dollars
out of the bank
and i could go and i could go put it
literally uh you know in a vault
somewhere that i don't have control over
that's behind 10 passwords
uh and biometric scanning and like it's
really difficult to even get to it yeah
right
so if you almost look at it as like
there's three stages of security that
you could have in the traditional world
the same thing is true in bitcoin so you
could buy bitcoin on any exchange you
could do it on block five but you also
can do it on places like coinbase gemini
kraken etc also cash app
cash app you can do that i think i i
think there's
still sponsoring this podcast i'm not
biased at all
so once you get bitcoin on any of these
uh venues
uh you can leave it there on that venue
now the trade-off is you're taking
counterparty risk
so somebody else is responsible for the
security and the protection of it
uh in many cases big well-known
companies who have billions and billions
of dollars of assets
they have higher levels of security
that's why they're well known that's why
people trust them whatever but you are
taking counterparty risk
it is easier to quickly send to somebody
so this so the trade-off of like ease of
use
uh but counterparty risk is big and in
the bitcoin community specifically
this is a huge thing of uh they really
really advocate for
not leaving the bitcoin there right for
the the obvious kind of priority
the second thing you can do is you can
basically get it off of an exchange
and you can put it in some level of kind
of what i'll call a second layer of
storage
that second layer storage could be a
hardware device that you can quickly
just you know grab off your desk and
plug into your computer and immediately
use that's what they call like a
hardware wall hardware wallet yep
or you can have some sort of software
wallet right where it's not on an
exchange
but there is some level of uh in between
between the hardware wallet
and the exchange and the software wallet
but the software wallet is connected to
the internet
yeah and so um if you kind of think of
it as like the exchange
software wallet hardware wallet and then
there's something called deep storage or
cold storage
um and this is you know literally there
was a
company uh called zappo that uh would
put things in deep cold storage and it
was literally
buried in a mountain right so like
the odds that somebody's physically
going to go there there's armed guards
there's you know kind of all this type
of stuff
uh but again you're taking some level of
counterparty risk because they have your
bitcoin
and so the saying or the phrase uh is
not your
keys not your coins uh or as uh my buddy
isaiah jackson came up with he said uh
uh not your keys not your cheese right
in terms of uh
uh sovereignty is important right and
ultimately this goes back to kind of the
beginning of a conversation around
bitcoin's ethos
sovereignty right giving the power back
to people you don't have to rely on
this infrastructure in order to be able
to participate in this monetary
uh kind of economy which you are now
able to do is you're able to use
digital sound money you're able to keep
control of it you and you alone are
responsible for it so the idea of
personal responsibility
um and then also you and you alone make
the decisions as to
whether you hold on to it or you use it
without censorship right no one can tell
you what you can do with it or can't do
with it and so
the purchase and the storage what i find
is uh depending on who you are there's
varying
uh degrees of kind of concern or
decisions that get made there and a lot
of it comes down to personal preference
the bitcoin community though absolutely
will over optimize for
uh sovereignty and uh kind of hardware
or cold storage
i wonder if you can sort of comment on
that because you you have
uh both uh sort of uh cash app
and a blog fi and coinbase like you can
store it that you can purchase and trade
it there and store it there and so on
but ultimately they're saying you wanna
you know keep some of it there but you
want to move it to the hardware
wallet and the cold storage of the
hardware wallet is like you can
disconnect it from the computer because
ultimately stuff that's connected to the
internet
can be compromised can be controlled by
governments and other parties and so on
what are your thoughts about sort of
practically speaking for
maybe like a regular citizen
what's what should be the role of the
hardware wallet in their lives
yeah so at the highest level i just
think that like learning about it is
important
right so even if you only have five
dollars equivalent of bitcoin
going and understanding here's how it
works here's why it's important here's
how i would actually
withdraw from an exchange under the
hardware wall like that alone
just as an intellectual exercise is a
worthwhile pursuit i think people should
go do that
and actually go through the process of
the steps so you feel like you can
you can do it yeah yeah it's kind of
like if i said to you you know hey we're
gonna go buy an
asset and you never went and you looked
at it you never went and uh you know
made a decision like
sure maybe i did it or i didn't do it
but like you didn't actually experience
it right and so i think that that's the
important part
the second thing is uh each person is
different from a
how they view this asset so there are
some people who are speculating right
there's three use cases for bitcoin
there's store value medium of exchange
and speculation
and the people who are speculating they
can't put it in deep cold storage
because they need to be able to trade it
right so what ends up happening is
they fall in the bucket of like high
risk high reward they're
trying to trade they're trying to do all
these things and sure maybe there are
profits that they can generate if
they're good at it
but also they're introducing a lot of
risk and so that person is very
different than the person who says hey
you know i bought one bitcoin and i'm
gonna
save it for my child right and i'm going
to give it to them on their 18th
birthday
yeah and so when you start to look at
this what you end up saying
is what are you actually purchasing this
for kind of like why are you doing it
and then what's your time horizon and
what ends up happening
is more and more people in the bitcoin
community have longer time horizons one
of the advantages
to uh this community right if you look
at the on-chain metrics 60
of bitcoin haven't moved uh from the
digital wallet in which they sit
in the last 12 months so even though
it's appreciated hundreds of percent on
the upside
there's been lots of volatility a 50
drop in a single day
in terms of the us dollar price still
doesn't move and so these are kind of
the long-term holders right these are
the the iron fist or
as recently as become popular the
diamond hands right these
hands they're just they're not going
anywhere and so i think that
those people are much more likely to not
have their bitcoin on
exchanges or in software walls they've
got it in some sort of like highly
secure
environment uh and what and one in which
they have
deep sovereignty or kind of prevalent
sovereignty
and the reason for that is because they
have that long time horizon they don't
want to be
kind of convicted around bitcoin sound
money macro environment all stuff and
then they make a mistake because they
trusted
you know abcd company uh and that
counterparty risk because it ends up
actually being you know fatal or
detrimental
you